[Music]
Adidas and Puma are two of the biggest
rivals and shoes but did you know that
their founders were two halves of a once
happy family business that turned into a
level of brother rage so intense it will
get the sneakerheads tongues a wagon see
what I did there in the 1930s the
Dassler brothers sport shoe company in
Bavaria made the most kick-ass athletic
shoes in all the land the company even
gave Jesse Owens a pair of shoes to
compete in the 36 Olympics when Jesse
won the brothers shoes
blew up but all of that success was not
good for their relationship tensions
flared some say there was stealing
Affairs resentment and after World War 2
the brothers were so out of step they
eventually ended the company in 1949 8
off or Adi Dassler formed adidas a play
on his nickname Rudolf Dassler started
Puma because well that name is awesome
the brothers suit each other many many
times over the years over all sorts of
design and trademark issues costing each
other a fortune in lawyers and suits
their two factories built in the same
Bavarian village of pets and Genaro to
polarize the community with local people
picking sides by picking shoes
the brothers died two years apart they
are buried at opposite ends of the
village graveyard proof that even in
death there remained a great bitter
divide between them and so it was for
decades until 2009 employees of Adidas
and Puma in the village where the two
companies still have their head
corners came together and played a
friendly soccer match and started the
process of healing decades of em nity
and began a new era of love and shoes
[Music]
when I tell people I fix shoes they kind
of laugh then but I thought this
straight goes dead and I just kind of
like sometimes feel offended like no
it's not you know I'm trying to rise it
up we're gonna bring her though I have a
phrase called turn your beaters into
heaters still our people beat up the
shoes and that can make it look into
like someone fresh kicks I can make you
look brand new like wow you can actually
do this oh yeah I can throw your shoes
back to life I'm fixated Cakes that's
what I do and figures kick
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Joshua marine I'm 20 years
old and I'm a cobbler I grew up in the
north side of Chicago born and raised
I'm going oh hello I would always go to
my father's shop my father's a cop my
grandfather's a cobbler he taught me
everything that I know I was like you
know what I'm gonna take this to another
level I'm gonna bring my sneaker culture
in this and I'm gonna you know I'm gonna
go hard you know I'm did it I'm gonna do
this for a living when I started I was
about if stories and I would find shoes
and I would fix them up out repair him
touch him up there was one time where I
found a pair for 12 a pair of Georgian
12 I bought them for like thinking like
twenty one dollars I cleaned them up I
can't them up put new laces on them and
sold them for like around 180 bastard a
guy influenced into the sneaker culture
like hey you know I could make a living
off this I kept in the shoes and I could
sell him the cobbler ring it's like an
art form you know people live for this
big are like artists people designed
their own shoes a lot of teenagers
I want this colorway I can't find it
anywhere you know can you please provide
this for me oh yeah sure you know I
could paint it up for you I can make him
bleep how you want them it's always a
good feeling you know make people smile
and make people pleased with you know my
work you know because I've helped them
out and they help me out
[Music]
I feel like I to represent to knowledge
at college because that's you know
that's home or at home this is where I
belong just where I have to represent I
open up these shops within the year you
know a lot of people think that's crazy
like how did you do it you know like
what are you doing you know I'm just
hustling I get a lot of support from the
neighborhood when people come into the
shop but I know whose owner here
everybody all right
you're the team cobbler yeah that's me
so it makes me feel like home you know
it makes me feel like I belong here you
know I'm purposeful at first you know
this is what I'm known for
[Music]
Anish you need I probably have if I
don't have it I can get a fit in 24
hours if you're a rap and you have a
video shoot you neither shoes coming out
in two weeks I just have to make a call
and I'll get it for you
[Music]
every day millions of people tune to DJ
Khaled snapchat the key to more success
one of my favorite DJ kala pearance is
is this kid Ben how's business in a new
year oh I see you he's 16 years old and
he's at the helm of a burgeoning sneaker
Empire when he says has done nearly a
million dollars in business and boasts
clients like DJ Cod and Chris Brown meet
this sneaker Don so my name is Benjamin
capitalistic people call me Benjamin
cakes but most you guys know me as a
sneaker done school ends at three
o'clock I get home outlook for you
dinner
do some homework and go straight to the
office space and like any good Don
family's important I'm his manager so if
you need anything call me okay not that
family I'm the mother of the sneaker Don
to me he's my little boy but I also see
a business and he had a goal he's self
driven he's motivated he's a hard worker
the great Don's they say come from
humble beginnings the first pair of
sneakers actually got me a game I was in
fifth grade the Galaxy pack came out and
I got the LeBrons
gotta love sneakers after that probably
around sixth grade when my parents
didn't want to fund my sneaker hobby
anymore
I've to figure out a way how to get the
money for it and then I realized if I
buy five or ten pairs by paying people
to stand in line for me I could sell it
to a larger clientele and make more
money plus get my shoe for free and then
it just finally broke through and the
money you started coming in now first it
amazed me how sneakers can go for like
so much money for like one shoe people
were charging a thousand I thought it
was a good joke or something I was in
dollars but hey that's why he's the
sneaker Don
so what comes next really excited to
open up a physical store the first of
all cases I mean Miami and then I'm
trying to do la New York and Chicago all
my friends when they dropped out of
sneak game they like it's dead it's over
there's no more like you're not getting
on their thing you're wasting your time
and lose money not about what was true
play themselves indeed they did sneaker
Don indeed they did we can up every day
this thing you think I want to just moko
Jumbies is like chillin
[Applause]
[Music]
the tradition of moko Jumbies is a
special form of stilt-walking named
after a West African spirit who watches
over villages thanks to his towering
height in times of celebration groups of
Trinidadian dancers pay tribute to the
spirit but for Adrian loco Jumby is part
of his everyday life
my name is Deon young and I've been
walking stilts for 21 years the highest
I walked with my dance group is called
future Jumbies and it's a school for
anyone to live in to walk sticks the a
previous with dear Petronius ters we got
our shoes attached and then we have a
nice tie up and then we can have someone
raises up between starting on one foot
steps and then they gradually go up you
have overcome the fear for these are the
dance move and still look at limbo stoop
lara butterfly and the mocha tree in the
hardest movers the a split that's where
you take a proton
my favorite part of moko Jumbies dancing
is when my whole team that I trained
just killing it I feel a joy but then
doing nothing when I see my team giving
it their all and doing their routines I
feel a sense of pride and sometime feel
like sharing at it now by sense of
bringing everyone together
you